this particular type of bag despite not
being made for working out still
absolutely made the most sense 99 of
businesses just look at what other
businesses are doing and copy them
rather than just breaking all the way
down and being like what actually has to
happen I need to have something that
carries all of the stuff that I'm likely
to use I don't want it to take a lot of
space I need to have easy access to
everything so I don't have to dig around
in the dark trying to feel around where
my stuff is what I did sacrifice with
that one is that it's not a back strap
like that would have been a nice
addition but I'm willing to sacrifice
the fact that it didn't have a back shot
for all the other benefits